Hausa Gomez - Parris welcome to the
forest this is probably one of the most
anticipated horror games of the year I
went a long time to play this it's gonna
be awesome
hopefully I don't want to pipe it up too
much cuz it might not be like right and
it's not even out yet this is actually a
public alpha so you know it says here
all of whatever but let's just play
because I really want to really want to
try this out I'm so eager to play this
it's an open world survival horror game
and it's not multiplayer so it's not
[ __ ] Daisy or some [ __ ] not nothing
against that but I don't know I'm more
interested in the concept of an open
world horror game I don't think that it
really has ever been done before in a
single-player game and that's pretty
awesome I might be talking out of my ass
hair but I'd never [ __ ] heard of it
and so we'll see if we'll manage to
survive in the forest so it starts of
course in the skies it looks very pretty
maybe it's just me being not being picky
but oh that's cute he's gonna die and
what are we watching the necklace oh god
that looks is that a real horror movie
my girlfriend would know she oh [ __ ]
well that would sound fast in it
literally what the [ __ ] are you see
still sleeping no it's gotta be okay
Timmy don't hold my head squeeze it a
holic to can think about ponytails
we still a my ow the necklace hurt man
Oh God
Timmy whoa what the [ __ ] are you don't
you dare take Timmy don't you dare take
Timmy why would you want oh yes it is
okay I understand the legacy needs to
continue all right well now we know why
we're in the forest and why we're
covered in blood Low Energy find
medicine and we're hungry well we should
find a lot of these stuff in the plane I
think she got brutally murdered I'll
take that now oh cool that's awesome so
there's these tribes people let's just
[ __ ] eat everything oh oh I would you
know what if I was in the forest I would
probably make this my home it's a pretty
good base you got a roof over yourself
wind protection it's not bad isn't it oh
god it's that a crocodile hot chop
that's not a crocodile that's a lizard
I knew that and we skinned that [ __ ]
and we added a rock to our backpack
because a man I don't think we need to
collect all these rocks that seems
pretty dumb that's a lot hmm what if we
can find the key somewhere and here we
have some microchips that could be
useful in the far future I don't know
how long this game is I hope it will be
very long because it seems awesome so
far learn basic of survival press B to
open its rubber yes I always keep this
handy underneath my shirt in case
something happens
all right a shelter restoring energy
hide from predators save your game
bigger okay so you can save and [ __ ]
also I can build a shelter cool but I'm
not interested in that right now thank
you I need and I have all that right
six-four
logs no I don't have all that let's step
to build a fire basic survival all right
so we need to find four rocks six six
and four logs one what happened do we
need a bigger backpack oh that bunny
[ __ ] scared me we should kill it
where is it
[ __ ] I lost it you're dead you're dead
meat [ __ ] no you win this round
mr. bunny but you would not win them all
oh [ __ ] there is a choice people what
the hell are they doing already the [ __ ]
are they doing oh god they don't like me
do they well I have an axe charge
[ __ ] you took my Timmy [ __ ]
what oh why don't you die of an axe you
should be dead long ago I slice your
tits to boot
whoa nice hot brother oh god they're
like zambie cannibals that don't seem to
give a [ __ ] that I'm murdering them god
Gabe [ __ ] God what do I have to do to
kill you the [ __ ] lizard eyes on one
stroke why don't you die on one stroke
what was that oh god there's more of
them wash it off to avoid infection
lufthansa god damn it I knew I shouldn't
have fly with them they can [ __ ] jump
in out what all right now you're just
[ __ ] with me well I hear water so
let's go yeah let's water over there
this game is weird man this is not what
I expected at all and it has intention
before you start fighting people you
can't just [ __ ] let them attack me
like that I get that able to be scarier
in the dark but still that's [ __ ]
weird man
oh I am without a head in that Seth
that's all fine let's just take a little
wash that don't wash
a little wash their big overall cleaner
thank you thank you thank you that looks
something that we should kill
it's a flying fish I say and it should
die oh no it's a bird
oh no I thought it was a flying Fig oh
that's another one Kelly all right I
need to extort two better survival stop
oh it's there I is inventory I didn't
see that cuz the graphics are so alright
second I have a stick I can have that I
need to throw away my lizard
I'm sorry literally I can I can fight
with my lizard or I can cook the listen
you know what I am NOT gonna use the
listen I'm gonna use you what if I start
my camp somewhere anyway let's let's try
it place a shelter
alright um rotate it you know what have
we want to have a nice view of this
condo my cell apartment I don't know I'd
probably yeah here here's a good spot a
little angled there you go now yes this
is how you build in Sweden you [ __ ]
smack all that [ __ ] on something new you
now we need more logs and sticks
now we don't mean uh you're so silly
so we're supposed to shop down the wood
is that it no it's one ugly mushroom
this is not as easy as minecraft I guess
oh my god
we're doing it minecraft I always wanted
to play Minecraft
alright it's gonna follow me right now
isn't it better be safe alright timber
I thought there we go timber yeah yeah
yes that's awesome this game is cool I'm
approving of this game I don't know why
I cut the tree that is the furthest away
ever this is gonna be a great series for
us I can feel it in my fingers let's cut
down a tree a little closer how about
you seed sorry Steve no made a collie
Steve this this is a is that a stick my
god I almost missed you this game would
be cool with oculus I don't know every
time like I think about this game no you
know what I'm gliders isn't in the game
but I'm still very impressed how
detailed it is for an indie game it's
better than how that triple hate titles
which maybe really doesn't say much
these days at all but let's put you in
there we need a couple more what a cute
house were building here breath we're
gonna have a great time I'm enjoying
this usually don't enjoy survival games
either because they're so boring to get
into but even this is easy I like it or
you play online and you [ __ ] get
killed by some higher level dude right
away and it's like oh yeah that was fun
I enjoy that a lot no I or it's this
empty and you have no [ __ ] idea what
it was to do I don't get it I get it if
you play with friends but if you play oh
no in the water oh god they dumped way
more than I thought the cheese I only
found like three of them all right three
more I probably would not have been be
doing this like the first day I probably
more like look for [ __ ] food or
shelter or trying to find my son but I
don't know I don't really give a [ __ ]
about teaming I stay on it like I was
gonna adopt him away to a cannibal
anyway like that's what I was going it's
going through some weird third world
country to get rid of him and Oh two
more sticks all right oh that's the
second boy is a second
oh yeah high-fiber best house ever to
fill energy save game alright cool
let's save our game Oh your present oh
god it's night now I don't know if I
like that you know I'm going back to
sleep
[ __ ] that I'm not ready for night oh
[ __ ]
alright that's a nice red see that is a
pre-alpha it's a give and take this is
what you get
we really should make a fire ok can we
make a fire we need seven leaves and two
sticks
got it that's a stick are you with stink
yes you're a stick you're istic and my
thing alright oh no I feel I feel so bad
for Jimmy he's probably all alone and
scared
alright let's put you there
actually sound of leaf I have my lighter
here luckily voila heavy I have five a
little bit all right now in my belly is
rumbling a little I could do with some
some mushrooms and some rum alright my
lizard give me a kiss alright you will
now be cooked maybe I should read a
cooking book first alright so we have
the shelter check we have the fire check
step three what's that basic survival
step three shut up
alright here's an example of two similar
poison looking also looking berries one
is edible the other one's poisonous this
is edible because it has the blueberries
the twin berry black color and forming
pairs
duly noted have you seen into the wild
where he eats it wrong I don't want to
spoil it but he eats the wrong leaves
and something happens you can get us
need [ __ ] dice okay so that's the
basics we have this basic fire a fire
pitch standing fire what the [ __ ] oh we
should build that yeah that'd be cool
that's cooler my god this is like lizard
we're gonna have the best house ever
here this is gonna be so cool I'm gonna
love this
listen girl you're my best friend man we
should figure out how to make it torch
this is [ __ ] dark and [ __ ] whoa
I can refill fill that what am I doing
here
oh no don't kill me lizard
oh god you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my you are so [ __ ] dead you piece
I nearly had a [ __ ] heart attack
you don't do that [ __ ] oh where am I
oh he abducted me well he didn't take my
[ __ ] so he I'm gonna [ __ ] their [ __ ] up
oh my sweet lord baby Jesus yeah so oh
that's an elderly mother [ __ ] isn't it
Pacman's to eat so they collect us for
some reason
in this weird cave I don't like it not
one oh god that's pants ugly out of
style pants oh God
I don't what is that soil and a garden
yes
alright let's find our home Bryce let's
find it where is it though there must be
one not a way out of this godforsaken
place I'm still not over that scare man
I thought I was safe as [ __ ] man I
thought we were fine and that's when
they [ __ ] charged at me and I didn't
like where am i exactly here I don't get
it there's an home song I felt off the
this game is really
[ __ ] bug isn't it that's kind of a
yeah I fell off the map okay don't shove
it in my face you know what that's gonna
have to do for the first episode because
I'm gonna keep the series a little
longer I'm gonna keep the episode long I
know we have a lot of stuff going on
right now but I really want to play what
I'm into playing but please do leave a
like if you enjoyed watching and I'll
see you tomorrow with a new one so stay
awesome bros love you